What should we all carry in our wallet?
When I went through Lauren's wallet, I noticed that she was carrying about 45 dollars in cash.
This is exactly appropriate.
Don't carry a lot of cash in your wallet.
The average person who loses their wallet will lose a few times throughout their lifetime.
Next up, we are going through your credit cards.
You won't need to carry no more than two in your wallet and ideally from two different vendors.
A lot of people, and I've been guilty of this myself, carry receipts around in their wallet.
They have a lot of identifying information on them.
They have the last four digits of your credit card and worse they have your signature.
That means that they could actually use your credit card...
...and sign your name almost exactly as you signed it.
And lastly, something that was so interesting that you did that I was so proud of is...
...Lauren has a picture of her when she's little.
Is she not the most precious child?
It's just an interesting fact to know that if you have a baby photo or even a puppy photo,...
...you have a much higher likelihood of someone returning your wallet.
So that's all the tips that we have for you today.
I hope you look through your own wallet and make sure that you're not a big offender.